So I'm not here to tell you,
don't do this,
do that,
don't do that,
do this.
I'm here to change the way you think and
if I can change the way you think,
I can't help but change what you do,
can I?
So I'm going to take your brains out of
your head,
squish them up and stuff and back in
again and change your world.
That's my goal today.
Let me introduce you to the concept of
success.
Ben Franklin was a pretty smart guy and
I want to start with a quote by him.
If you do tomorrow,
what you did today,
you won't get tomorrow.
What you got today?
Want to know what that means?
The average American makes between three
and five percent more each year.
That's the deal.
And in today's economy,
I'm not sure we're going to make the
three to four to five percent.
Next year is employed,
so it takes you 20 years ago,
double your income in America as an
average.
That's the mediocrity that was stuck in
and then give me uncanny ability to
double their income in the year.
I got promoted five times in a year.
The ones that beat the system once the
contract,
your last name of having a difference
between them and the ones that don't do
that is that they wake up in the morning
and they think differently.
We're going to look at every aspect of
our lives.
We go see what we doing,
right?
What was your role?
We're going to analyze this thing and
when we come out of the lab,
maybe we're going to be bigger boned up,
be better.
Are you hearing what I'm saying?
And so if you wanted to have it up and
make it happen,
if we wanted to have it rise and ride,
if you wanted to happen,
you want to do what I do and that's to
get up at 3:00 in the morning if be
wanted to have it,
that means you don't have to get home at
2:15 and get your butt up in troy six.
I was lucky.
I found what I love to do.
The heaviness of being successful was
replaced by the lightness of being a
beginner.
Again,
less.
I convinced that the only thing that
kept me going was that I loved what I
did.
You got to find what you love and that
is as true for work as it is for your
lovers.
Your work is going to fill in large part
of your life and you only way to be
truly satisfied is to do what you
believe is great.
Only way to do great
if you haven't found it yet,
keep looking.
Don't settle her.
As with all matters of the heart,
you'll know when you find it in like any
great relationship,
it just gets better and better.
As the years went along.